Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture you've been
learning about vector calculus,
Stokes' theorem, all sorts of
cool stuff like that, curl.
So I have a nice
problem here for you.
So let F be the
following vector field.
So it's the vector
field whose direction
is x i hat plus y
j hat plus z k hat,
but in addition I want to
multiply it by rho to the n.
So this is your usual rho
from spherical coordinates.
This is the square
root of x squared
plus y squared plus z squared.
And n can be any number.
So it might be positive,
it might be negative,
it might be 0, doesn't
have to be an integer.
Some number, though,
it's some constant.
So what I'd like you to do is
to show that for this field,
regardless of what the
value of n happens to be,
that it is a gradient field.
So it is the gradient
of some function.
So why don't you pause the
video, have a go at that,
come back and we can
work on it together.
So recall that for something to
be a gradient field, what that
means-- well, first
of all, that means
that there is some function
that has it as the gradient,
and we know a lot of other
characterizations of it.
And one of them that we
know involves the curl.
So let's talk about that one.
So in order to look at
the curl of this field,
I'm going to want to
take partial derivatives
of its components.
And so I'm going to want to
take partial derivatives of rho.
So let's just remember or
recall that partial rho
partial x equals x over rho.
And similarly, partial rho
partial y is y over rho.
And partial z partial--
sorry, partial rho partial z
is z over rho.
So you can just check that using
the fact that you know what rho
is.
Et cetera.
I'm going to write et
cetera because it's
the same for the other two.
So let's call-- for
shorthand-- let's call F,
M*i plus N*j plus P times k.
So M, N, and P are
its components.
If F is this, then
we know that curl F
is equal to-- what is it?
So it's P, the y-th
partial derivative of P,
minus the z-th partial
derivative of N,
i hat, plus-- OK, so it's the
z-th partial derivative of M
minus the x-th partial
derivative of P, j hat, plus--
it's going to be,
what's the last one?
The x partial derivative of N,
minus the y partial derivative
of M, k hat.
So if this is our
formula for F, then this
is our formula for
the curl of F. And OK,
so now we just have to compute
these various different partial
derivatives in order to
see what the curl is.
And then hopefully that'll tell
us something about this field.
So let's see.
So P_y.
In our case, so M is equal to
rho to the little n times x.
Big N is equal to rho
to the little n times y.
And big P is equal to rho
to the little n times z.
So let's look at
our components here.
So P sub y-- well, z is a
constant with respect to y.
So this is just rho to the n.
Well, z times the y-th
partial of rho to the n.
So that's by the
chain rule, so we
got n rho to the n minus 1
times y over rho times z.
So we can rewrite this as
n*y*z rho to the n minus 2.
And similarly-- so
that was P sub y,
so let's look at N sub z.
So N is rho to the n times y.
So you take the z-th partial
derivative, so y is a constant.
So we need to look at the
z-th partial derivative of P
to the n.
So this is, again,
it's n-- sorry,
I think I said P to the n.
But of course this isn't
a P, this is a rho.
So it's n rho to the n minus 1
times partial rho partial z--
so that's z over rho-- times y.
And again, this is equal to
n*y*z rho to the n minus 2.
OK, so P sub y,
the y partial of P,
is n*y*z rho to the n minus 2.
And the z partial of n is
n*y*z rho to the n minus 2.
And they're the same.
So what does that mean?
So that means the first
component of curl of F is 0.
So if you do a little
bit more arithmetic
of exactly the same
sort-- you have two more
components to check--
what you're going to find
is that the other
ones are 0 also.
I'm not going to do out all
those partial derivatives
for you, but I trust that you
can compute the similar looking
partial derivatives that appear
in these other two components--
this j should have had a hat--
the other partial derivatives
that appear in these components
and show that they're all also
equal to 0.
So in our case, curl of F is
just equal to the zero vector.
OK, great.
So what does that mean?
Well, we want to show that
something is a gradient field.
So we know that we can do that.
We know that that happens
precisely when its curl is 0,
if it's defined on a
simply connected domain.
On a simply connected region.
So we know that a function
is a gradient field
if it's defined on a
simply connected domain
and has curl 0.
Well, let's see.
So where is this thing defined?
Where is F defined?
Well, if n is bigger than
or equal to 0-- well,
I guess I want strictly
bigger than 0 just
to be on the safe side.
If n is positive, this
is defined everywhere
and we're great.
If n is negative, then
we have a problem at 0.
Because then we have
division by rho.
So we don't want to divide by 0.
So if n is negative, there's
a problem at the origin.
So in the worst case,
F is defined everywhere
except the origin.
But that's simply connected.
Because we're in space.
If we were in the plane, this
would be a different story.
But in space, just
removing a point
doesn't destroy
simply connectedness.
So this field F is
defined everywhere,
except the origin
perhaps, so we're
in a simply connected region.
So when you have curl F in
a simply connected region,
your field is, in
fact, a gradient field.
Now I leave it as
an exercise to you
to come up with the
actual function,
or one of the actual functions,
of which this is a gradient.
But we've just shown
that because its curl
is 0, and because it's defined
in a simply connected region
of space, that this field
really is the gradient field
of some function.
So I'll stop there.